Ми спілкуємося з надзвичайними і
повноважним послом Німеччини в Україні
пані анкою фельдгузин і ми це робимо з
досить незвичного місця лише з іншого
боку для киян Мабуть звичне це укриття
тому що ми записуємо цей інтерв'ю під
час повітряної тривоги чергової
повітряної тривоги в Києві пані онко не
можу вас не запитати А вчора у понеділок
тобто мабуть був перший для вас ракетний
обстріл світком якого ви стали тому що
це перший такий масований обстріл
столиці з того часу як посольство
повернулося в Київ Як ви пережили цей
день Це дійсно перший Просто як я чула
мене тому що 24 ми були в Житомирі Я це
просто не чула
Це було Це страшно можна так сказати
дуже голосно і я просто зрозуміла не те
що українці вже живуть це 230 Ні тому що
факт що в Києві було відносно спокійно
останні місяці не пови
нен нас на сходити на півдні і українці
там кожен день мають такі
відчуття Ви писали у себе в соцмережах
що перебували в укриті разом на сотною
киян Що вас вразило мені були такі
спокійні грали
там люди просто намагалися дізнатися
більше на через знайомих добре що
телефон функціонує
скрізь і завжди Скажіть будь ласка з
враховуючи ось цей вчорашній ракетний
обстріл Чи можемо ми сподіватися на
більшу підтримку з боку Німеччини в
плані зброї вже оголосили про те що нам
нададуть нову систему протиповітряної
оборони Коли це може статися і Чи можемо
сподіватися на щось більше
рішення
постачати України не проти повітря
і перша система буде дуже скоро наш
міністр Я думаю що 10 днів в тому
сказала що ці дні дня більше я теж не
знаю про це але я думаю що це було добре
рішення Сподіваємось що ми
всі хочемо передати ні теж будуть скоро
Тому що це перше за все те що Україна
зараз потребує
якщо до Танків
Це ця дискусія продовжується В Німеччині
з нашими партнерами подивимось
Поки що немає чітких термінів Ні нема
термінів ви знаєте що сьогодні є відео
конференція
характерна наша це
і там тема і будуть інші чи зараз
можливості про це говорити
це дуже жива жвава дискусія в Німеччині
ви можете
Я впевнена що ми всі наші партнери разом
Прийма
є рішення чи думаєте Ви що щось
зміниться враховуючи вчорашній події у
рішенні партнерів
скажемо так
такий
удар з прямо в столітці Ні це з
психологічно в наших країнах
безперечно
впливає тому що
це
дасть просто інші враження у нас це
жахливо сказати і досить синична тому що
дійсно українці вже так духа
живуть це
з цим можливо що дійсно наші
й політиці Я сподіваюсь ми зараз не
можемо виключати нічого і часто говорять
і про застосування ядерної зброї навіть
якщо Путін застосує ядерну зброю як
відреагує Німеччина
ми ці рішення дійсно приймаємо разом з
нашими партнерами є в НАТО У нас є цей
Альянс і я впевнена що вони вже не в
дискусіях президента
Меркель не раз говорила що не варто
ігнорувати погрози Путіна в тому числі
ядерні погрози чи поділяються ви таку
думку Ну ми 24 лютого точно ми бачили що
краще вірити в те що він пише Або каже
Тобто ми не відключаємо нічого але Чи
означає це що Україна тоді має скласти
зброю ні
Україна ну бореться ну кожен день за
свою
свободу за факт що Україна не існує як
держава і теж за наших цінності і ми
намагаємось дійсно кожен день
підтримувати Україну ми в цій боротьбі
чи я сам сідати за стіл переговорів з
Путіним
Мені здається що зараз точно не часто
Україна повинна
не видно України і потім ми це буде
рішення українського у
ряду що робити останнє запитання про
нового посла України в Німеччині Олексій
макеєв він замінить доволі таки
неординарного за своїм стилем дипломатії
Андрія Мельника Як ви думаєте чи
зміниться щось у дипломатичних
відносинах України і Німеччини чи
можливо посилиться підтримка Німеччини
Ми підтримуємо Україну тому що Україна
стала
жертви нападу Росії вже 8 років тому і
вони більше нас вже всі ці роки
підтримували Україні і більше ще з 24
лютого це не залежить від послів Я знаю
і Андрія Мельника і олек Макеева дуже
добре ну це старі знайомі я вже впевнена
що Олекса
як і всіх українських е-е слів
добре в Німеччині Я з ним дуже добре вже
зараз співпрацюємо Дякую вам за центр я